alright let's get started with Google
i/o genesis has introduced what's going
on with that
so gluconeogenesis gluco refers to
glucose mio refers to new and genesis
refers to generate or to make
so basically cuckoo neo Genesis is
making new glucose so specifically it's
making glucose from two pyruvates so in
a way it's kind of undoing glycolysis
however it is not the exact reversal of
glycolysis so why is that well because
there are three irreversible glycolytic
steps right like in glycolysis there are
three are irreversible steps that need
different enzymes to be reversed so I
know I know you're there irreversible by
that enzyme that doesn't mean those
processes are impossible to undo it's
just that they're they don't get undone
by the same enzyme that catalyzes the
forward reaction okay so we need
different enzymes in order to reverse
those steps so how many steps are there
in gluconeogenesis because in glycolysis
there were ten well in gluconeogenesis
there's actually 11 and that's because
the step catalyzed by pyruvate kinase I
relate kinase in glycolysis must be
undone or reversed with two enzyme
catalyzed steps so all the glycolytic
reactions are reversed with one step
except this one the one that's catalyzed
by pyruvate kinase so because this one
is reversed in two separate steps
there's one more reaction right so hence
the 11 total okay so that means there's
four different or new enzymes that undo
the irreversible glycol glycolytic steps
right these are four new enzymes or
different enzymes in gluconeogenesis
okay now quickly know Genesis is an
energy requiring pathway which is sort
of the opposite of glycolysis which
created energy and in this process we're
building glucose and it's anabolic and
reductive okay which again is opposite
of glycolysis
the energy that for for buckling in
Genesis is supplied by fatty acid
oxidation also known as beta oxidation
okay and this is this occurs during the
fasted state when you're fasting your
body taps on of fats for energy right
breaking down fatty acids okay now as
far as going through and building a
glucose there are six ATP equivalents
that are used for in the form of ATP and
two in the form of gtp so 680 be
equivalent saw required to make each
glucose right this is a per glucose
number okay now the the reciprocal
regulation right with a hormonal e with
like insulin and glucagon make sure that
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis which are
opposing past pathways do not occur at
the same time in the same cell okay
there are cases in which you could have
the two two pathways sort of occurring
at the same time in separate tissues
right different cells but but not it
would make no sense to have to be
breaking down and eat and making glucose
at the same time in the same cell okay
now of course we can we're making
glucose from two pyruvates as we
mentioned earlier okay but where are
those carbons coming from can they come
from anywhere else other than just
pyruvate
well pyruvate can can come from from
lactate right through the lactate
dehydrogenase reaction also glycerol
which is the backbone for fats can be
used in gluconeogenesis and also amino
acids can provide the carbon skeleton
that is used in gluconeogenesis okay
you